i'm your new commanding officer captain
ray holt jacob peralta
amy santiago she and peralta have some
big bet over who gets more rest this
year
she's got a type which is really anyone
but
you jake peralta is an amazing detective
genius
jake wins amy loses
[Music]
i do not like amy when you finally go
out with me and you will
it'll be because i do things that only
charles boyle would do doug judy is the
pontiac bandit i haven't been much fun
to hang out with over the last year or
so
on account of all the asking you out and
smelling your hair and
staring at you from point blank range
thanks dad
detective we'd like you to go undercover
okay the answer is yes i kind of wish
something
could happen between us romantic styles
i'm celebrating my name's jake peralta
and i just got
fired from the nypd
back in the nine-nine whoa
jake captain wunch good to see you
but if you're here who's guarding hades
you got your task force i'm surprised
captain
raymond holt you are an amazing police
captain
slash genius charles boyle and i had sex
do you have any regrets no doug
judy aka the pontiac bandit foiled at
last
greetings from paradise you terry
jeffords
are pregnant i was looking for an excuse
to promote you to a death job
and you handed it to me on a silver
platter with your little rat hands
remember when you told me i got a new
rule i don't date cops
that really bummed me out man
well this is happening huh i'm leaving
the nine-nine effective immediately
what the hell i don't understand what
the hell why are you doing this
what the hell okay here we go
hello i'm your new commanding officer
i'm having a heart attack name the
pigeon
paulie screw just being colleagues and
screw light and breezy do you want to
have a ticket taco at the
on on the bench over there sure i'm back
amy santiago is an amazing detective
slash genius
you'll never get away from me judy
don't be a dumb dog squad meet detective
adrian pimento
we got engaged someone's trying to kill
me i'm a contract killer who was hired
to kill agent pimento jimmy the butcher
figgis has a man in the fbi
and he tried to have pimento kill
i will find that fbi agent and i will
rip his head off with my bare hands
maura told me who figgis has working for
him in the fbi yeah i already know who
he is because i just caught him
did you get the other guy what other guy
someone named bob anderson
oh bob we have more than enough evidence
to take you and figures down this is
jimmy figgis i'm gonna
kill you both i see hey
grab greg ah that was it what if we
don't find figures
what are figgis finds us
huh oh
i'm transferring the whole squad to the
night shift ginatti
is the ultimate human slash genius
we're back on the day shift the pontiac
bandit
hey baby nice legs way to go
i'm shutting the 99 down and there is
nothing you can do
about it the precinct will not be shut
down
lieutenant melanie hawkins oh no
she dirty no no no no no we're nypd
officers this is an undercover operation
that's a lie peralta you thought you
were gonna take me down
you are not gonna get away with this oh
i already did we're
innocent guilty
go go go go go go go go go go go
go go cool sarge
captain so how's prison what do you want
seamus to help
i know your boyfriend got framed maybe i
could give you the proof you need to
take down the cop that set him up
checkmate
now that's a chess move uh it's so good
to be back
amen brother did my information prove
useful you were right
good and now you owe me a favor
amy santiago will you marry me
what's going on is captain holt has an
interview to become the commissioner of
the freaking nypd
i'm compromised we'll all figure out
what to do about murphy i'm bisexual
you tell your husband kevin i'll see him
real soon two months in a safe house
that's not impossible how much longer
will he be forced to live inside this
pizza pocket you're both gonna die
now
so i wake in the morning and i step
outside
and i take a deep breath and i get real
high oh my god i'm gonna be a surgeon i
do
i absolutely do well from the look on my
face i'm sure you can guess what it says
you got it i got it oops i misread the
email
we are going on a mega baller honeymoon
captain holt
what is it about me that screams
loser i'm gonna go directly to the mayor
the nine-nine is at war with the nypd
i'm handing in my two weeks notice to
terry jeffords the ultimate human being
slash
genius i do want to have kids with you
i've been sent here to spy on you we
could turn kelly's agent into a double
agent what is happening he's triple
crossing us
did you do something cool i did
something very cool i've got you on tape
kelly you're screwed
using illegal wiretaps or something you
got me you have a dark knight machine
yes i do we can still stop
john kelly i made a suicide squad you
want us your enemies to help you bring
down commissioner kelly you've betrayed
us you
coffin cave mold beetle we got it
peralta
i told her that i'd only spent a month
as a patrolman before i made detectives
she said that's against regulations and
has decided to
hi i'm officer debbie fogle i think i
might be pregnant oh damn
i'm not i got my period should we just
start trying
nope somebody stole 20 bricks of coke
and some machine guns from evidence what
it's the first i'm hearing of it
took the coke and the guns yeah right
now it's debbie let's get debbie into a
cop car
lunch is dead bagel are we having a baby
we're having a baby i just became the
first three-time
champion indeed indeed indeed indeed
uh what was that the water just broke
which reminds me we should be prepared
to distribute emergency water and food
your water just broke i'm kind of in the
middle of something you
oh yeah well
[Laughter]
yourself all right
meet mac short for mclean i said surely
you